como um esporte com tão poucos
praticantes no brasil com mais grima
entrou na minha vida
bom eu entrei nesse clima por influência
do meu irmão e do meu primo
ambos eram grandes fãs de star wars e
eles adoravam lutar com sabres de luz
dentro de casa
obviamente os meus pais meus filhos não
gostavam muito disso porque eles acabam
destruindo tudo ea minha tia jô como
solução botar meu primo na esgrima
quando meu primeiro torneio grima o meu
irmão resolveu entrar também e eu passei
a freqüentar a sala de esgrima todos os
finais de semana que ele tinha
competição eu adorava assistir nos dias
de semana eu esperava ainda deve acabar
para brincar com ele com saber de
borracha como eu era menor de 10 anos e
ainda não pôde entrar no esporte
então em 2007 eu quando completei dez
anos
eu entrei no sport eu me apaixonei por
isso em 2008 eu competi nos primeiros
torneios nacionais
em 2009 eu competi meu primeiro torneio
internacional
então eu percebi que fazer isso eu
competi e viajar que são duas coisas que
eu gosto muito pra mim não tem preço e
era o que eu queria fazer da minha vida
com a minha palestra eu esperava muito
estimular alguém a começar um esporte e
que mais que eu soubesse o que é esse
clima e se no final da minha palestra
que vai conseguir fazer isso voltar
realmente muito feliz
então vou tentar explicar o sport por
cima porque na verdade um esporte muito
complexo
mesmo os pais que acompanham o esporte
desde a época do meu irmão sabem tudo
sobre ele e continuo muitas vezes
torcendo quando o ponto não é meu
então eu vou começar apresentando as
armas são três armas
o florete o sabre ea espada
esse é o florete e seu sabre e essa
espada
bom então as diferenças de cada um eu
vou começar falando do florete porque a
arma que eu pratico só pode tocar no
tronco e só valeu o toque de ponta ou
seja as pessoas usam uma superfície
metálica no
tronco que se chama colete e quando toca
outra é tocado acende uma luz colorida
no sabre
essa superfície metálica vai da cintura
pra cima então o toque sua área da
cintura pra cima
isso pode tocá além de ponta também pode
trocar de lado e na espada pode tocar só
de ponta mas no corpo inteiro então ano
pode tocar nos pés nos braços e na
cabeça
as pessoas jogam numa superfície
metálica que tem 14 metros de
comprimento e dois metros de largura a
gente chama de pista e quando um jogador
sair dessa área obviamente a ponto do
adversário na frente dessa pista fica
colocado um juiz e ele recebe a função
de decidir de quem é o ponto quando as
duas luzes coloridas assentem então ele
vai analisar se a formação ofensiva
formação defensiva e por isso esporte
tão complexo
a a competição ela se divide em duas
fases é mais ou menos que em uma copa do
mundo de futebol as pessoas separadas em
grupos e só joga o primeiro entre esses
grupos que são chamadas as folhas então
seus jogos em cinco pontos ou em três
minutos
então ganha quem chegar a cinco pontos
primeiro ou se os três minutos de jogo
passarem ganha quem tiver na frente aí
as folhas servem pra classificar pra ver
com quem vai jogar nas eliminatórias nas
eliminatórias do já vai quando perdesse
automaticamente eliminado
e é um jogo em 15 pontos ou em três
tempos de três minutos então é a mesma
coisa se acabou o tempo em que estiver
na frente ou quem fizer 15 pontos 1º
durante esses três minutos o intervalo
de um minuto pode descansar e conversar
com o técnico a esgrima apesar de todos
os esportes na verdade ela pode ser um
pouco complicada porque tu tem que
conciliar ela com o colégio e eu acabei
dando um pouco de tempo eu treino cinco
vezes por semana três horas por dia e
muitas vezes a gente treinar os feriados
e nas férias também também um esporte
caro porque todo esse material elétrico
é de um custo elevado e as viagens
também são
pagas pelos meus pais na maioria das
vezes os também caras também eu acabei
dando muitas provas muitos trabalhos
muitas aulas
então eu tenho que fazer todas as provas
da semana de trimestrais e fica uma
semana bem corrida pra mim é realmente
uma semana eu tenho que me esforçar
muito
então acaba sendo bem cansativo além do
desgaste físico que tu tem porque como a
gente treina muito muita gente tem
lesões e tudo mais mas apesar de tudo
isso eu amo o que eu faço eu já viajei
para vários países com a esgrima e para
vários países que eu também nunca iria
se não tivesse uma competição há tipos b
questão e isso acabou tirando o
preconceito de lugares pitot que não tem
nada pra ver nada pode conhecer na
verdade tem muita coisa legal pra tv
também e eu também acabei conhecendo
pessoas de outros lugares do brasil e de
outros lugares do mundo isso é realmente
muito legal eu gosto muito disso e me
tornei uma pessoa mais comprometida
porque eu sabia que para continuar
fazendo o que eu amo eu tinha que passar
nas provas e tinha que estudar porque os
meus pais sempre portaram como condição
de continuar fazendo isso que eu
passasse em todas as provas e como
continuar sendo bem no colégio
então eu também me tornei uma pessoa
muito mais independente dos meus pais
porque eu viajo geralmente sozinha com
os meus companheiros de equipe como o
técnico mais igual
eu me tornei uma pessoa mais
independente e o meu sonho como de
qualquer atleta participar de uma
olimpíada
estou disposto a fazer qualquer coisa
pra isso porque a minha paixão é esgrima
com a paixão de vocês obrigada